[Musique]
bonsoir à tous début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 4 mai 2020 bienvenue
pour une nouvelle édition spéciale au
49e jour de confinement
depuis le jeudi 30 avril l'état classe
les départements en vert orange ou rouge
en fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie
objectif déterminer la manière dont se
fera le déconfinement au 3 mai 2020 les
yvelines sont classées en rouge
en clair le coronavirus a encore des
conséquences importantes sur le
territoire et le dé confinement total ne
peut avoir lieu même si le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation est
en baisse comme vous le voyez sur ses
courbes mais tout peut évoluer la
classification du jeudi 7 mai 2020 sera
prise en compte pour déterminer la
stratégie du déconfinement à partir du
11 mai et une inquiétude par rapport aux
déconfinement celle de 316 maires d'île
de france
il adresse au président de la république
emmanuel macron une lettre ouverte pour
lui demander de revoir sa copie quant à
la réouverture des écoles à compter du
11 mai
le calendrier est jugé intenable et
irréaliste et ils demandent également
conjointement de ne pas faire reposer la
responsabilité juridique politique et
morale de la réouverture des écoles sur
leurs épaules
parmi les signataires de ce courrier des
maires yvelinois ce d'elancourt de la
verrière ou encore de saint cyr l'école
on écoute justement cette dernière
propos recueillis par wilfrid riches
évidemment que tous les maires que nous
sommes frais temps à reprise de la vie
du pays qu'on veut bien sûr soutenir les
familles comptent pour qu'ils puissent
aller travailler il faut bien entendu
proposer un bus scolaire pour autant on
a un protocole qui tombe mercredi ou
jeudi dernier on a une semaine et demi
fait trois semaines que ça a été annoncé
ce protocole honnêtement les faits ne
sent aucune application correcte du
terrain aucune prise en charge
financière de ce que représente ce
surcoût et puis surtout une absence de
protection pénale pour l'humeur et a
fourni des masques aux personnels de
l'éducation nationale et nous on fait
quoi avec nos animateurs nous est saine
donc on n'en fournit aussi donc ça aussi
c'est un surcoût aujourd'hui les masques
on sait d'où ce en dehors du fait que
c'est un surcoût c'est aussi une denrée
rare
évidemment qu'on mettra en route la
cantine quel format je ne sais pas on a
tout entendu un certain derniers jours
ont fait manger l'enfant d'un biplace
ont laissé manger dans les territoires
ont pu des paniers repas
je suis en concertation avec à la fois
les parents d'élèves et avait à la fois
les enseignants comment on tient un
enfant de 8 ans dans une classe toute la
journée et avec la pause déjeuner dedans
qui est juste à côté
médaillée olympique en aviron un 2016 à
rio le rameur versaillais thomas baruch
est actuellement confiné en famille aux
généraux concours avant la crise
sanitaire il se préparer pour les jeux
olympiques de tokyo
alors comment passe-t-il ces journées
comment réagit-il au report de cette
compétition les éléments de réponse avec
aurélien 11
bonjour thomas baroque alors aujourd'hui
nous entamons notre huitième semaine de
confinement comment ça va ça va bien ça
va bien je suis chez moi je suis dans de
bonnes conditions puisque j'ai la chance
d'avoir un jardin d'une maison avec pas
mal de place j'ai les moyens de
continuer à m'entraîner je suis en
télétravail
donc globalement je suis pas à plaindre
et je supporte plutôt bien ces semaines
de confinement alors justement quand on
fait de l'aviron comment on fait pour
continuer à s'entraîner en étant confiné
alors on s'entraîne pas en bateau ça
c'est sûr on n'a pas de dérogation ou
d'autorisation particulière en tant que
sportif de haut niveau
je m'entraîne sur la rive au m donc
gérard meurt d'appartements qui simule
assez bien le mouvement de l'aviron avec
beaucoup de paramètres techniques qui
sont pas là mais mais au niveau
physiologique ça fait vraiment bien le
travail
et puis je fais aussi du vélo pas mal
vélo d'appartement et puis la
musculation puisque mon club m'a permis
de d'embarquer un peu de matériel juste
avant le début du confinement pour
pouvoir faire ça à la maison
vous savez en plaine une précis
entraînement matin une pause
entraînement l'après-midi comment ça se
passe oui effectivement j'ai une
organisation de nouveaux nés qui
ressemble à peu près ce qui se passe
quand on n'est pas en perte de
confinement la seule différence c'est
qu'il ya pas les déplacements
je m'entraîne le matin alors soit en
début de matinée soit en fin de matinée
ce départ un peu de de l'humeur de la
forme et puis des rendez vous que je
peux avoir ni aux professionnels aussi
je fais des jeunes normalement je suis
une petite sieste après je recommence à
travailler
et puis je suis le deuxième entraînement
en fin de fin d'après midi début de
soirée je suis dans la durée donc ces
disques une des journées qui ressemble
quand même pas mal à ce que je fais
habituellement à la différence près du
déplacement
vous êtes resté en contacts gmail aussi
avec votre collègue qui appliquent les
mêmes règles que vous les mêmes règles
et d'entraînement que voici
oui alors de toute façon au niveau
national on a en un programme qui est le
même pour tous les rameurs on a toujours
des contacts avec nos coachs au niveau
de la fédération donc
donc voilà c'est chacun organise un peu
ces journées comme il le peut et comme
il le veut fonction de ses contraintes
mais le problème entraînement à peu près
équivalent porte moins bien sûr vous
deviez participer au prochain aux
prochains jeux olympiques à tokyo qui
ont été reportée d'un an raison
évidemment de la crise sanitaire
comment vous avez réagi à cette annonce
alors je sais un petit peu à considère
que je devais y participent et
j'espérais pouvoir y participer
les sélections n'était pas encore
bouclée les qualifications du bateau
était pas encore obtenu donc
on n'était pas encore directement à se
préoccuper des jeux olympiques on était
plutôt à se préoccuper de pouvoir aller
au bout et c'est sûr que avec les
premières la première nouvelle qui a été
annoncée c'était l'annulation des
régates de la régate de qualification
donc potentiellement une qualification
sur tapis vert ce qui nous arrangeait
pas beaucoup parce que le bateau
français était pas bien parti pour se
qualifier cette façon là donc ça a été
un peu un soulagement ou en tout cas de
se dire qu on avait à nouveau nos
chances et notre destin entre nos mains
maintenant je ne sais toujours pas
quelle va être quelles vont être les
modalités de sélection au niveau
national pour l'année prochaine et
encore moins de qualification pour les
as dans la vie même si on se dit que
avec le temps qu'on s'est laissé
potentiellement pourrait repartir enfin
au copier ce qui était prévu pour cette
année pour l'année prochaine mais c'est
encore un point d'interrogation pour
l'instant on ne sait pas et c'est à peu
près normal parce que je pense que
personne ne sait vraiment à quoi va
ressembler les semaines et encore moins
les mois à venir
alors justement après le longe mais dont
la date a en théorie évidemment du début
du de déconfinement est ce que vous avez
eu des précisions concernant votre
entraînement est ce que ce sera possible
à l'extérieur par exemple
non j'ai pas vraiment une précision j'ai
juste eu un communiqué de presse du
ministère des sports
en plus moi je suis dans une situation
un peu particulière puisque je
m'entraîne dans le parc du château de
versailles donc qu' un autre acquis et
fermé en ce moment qui va
potentiellement le reste est donc
qu'est-ce que je vais réussir à être
considéré comme un sportif professionnel
à ce titre-là avoir le droit de me
déplacer et d'y accéder pour travailler
et donc pour m'entraîner pour l'instant
c'est encore des des interrogations
j'ai contacté des personnes qui doivent
prendre cette décision est pour
l'instant à temps mais c'est vrai qu'à
une semaine vu des conflits non je ne
sais pas vraiment quoi va ressembler la
semaine prochaine bon après quelques
jours de plus sur le rythme qui viennent
de s'écouler pendant huit semaines ça
sera pas un warm l'aubance vous avez
hâte j'imagine quand même de ces
confinement de retrouver justement le
contact avec l'eau par exemple
oui effectivement c'est ce qui manque le
plus les sensations qu'on peut avoir en
bateau on les retrouve nulle part
ailleurs donc et donc c'est clair que
c'est quelque chose qui finit par
manquer après c'est pas plus mal vie
leur fait que que ça manque un peu parce
qu'on se rappelle sa part et se rappeler
pourquoi on aime ce sport pour qu'on
aime aller à l'entraînement
c'est vrai que ça fait quelques années
maintenant que je rappe tôt une carrière
un peu longue maintenant et donc je suis
plutôt content d'enfin comptant dans la
mesure du possible mais c'est pas plus
mal finalement sept scènes coupées un
peu forcé
c'est une réorientation stratégique une
adaptation à la crise sanitaire
l'entreprise de les âges implantée à
elancourt a transformé sa production
spécialisée dans l'événementiel a décidé
de lancer la production de mobilier
destiné aux entreprises pour se protéger
du virus
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude mille présentoirs de gel
hydroalcoolique fabriqué en huit jours
voilà le bilan provisoire de la nouvelle
stratégie de deux les âges spécialisée
dans la fabrication de mobilier
d'événementiel cette entreprise s'est
réinventé des produits destinés à la
préparation du déconfinement pour les
entreprises notamment avec ses écrans de
protection en plexiglas pour les bureaux
sur des grandes plaques en trois parts
de on peut découper pas mal de pause
avec des systèmes de pied très très
simple à utiliser qui protège vraiment
tous les bureaux toutes les personnes
dans des accueils etc
techniquement il ya rien de nouveau
c'est juste des adaptations de forme
pour pouvoir créer en fait des produits
comme vous avez vu tout à l'heure
s'adapter aux besoins dans ce contexte
de crise sanitaire le choix opéré par la
dirigeante de cette société virginie
deneux ville
les premiers produits ont été pensés dès
le début du confinement
je me suis vraiment on fait une
réflexion sur les besoins galea voir les
gens en sortent et confinement c'est un
besoin physique et psychologique
physique parce qu'il faut se battre
contre un virus les psychologique parce
que si vous voulez que les salariés les
collaborateurs soit dans un état serein
pour reprendre leur travail
il faut leur montrer dans l'entreprise
qu'on met tout en oeuvre pour que y ait
zéro risque des cloisons de séparation
entre les bureaux des écrans de
protection pour les restaurants ou les
comptoirs d'accueil plusieurs gammes ont
été conçus avec une cinquantaine de
commandes programmer la production a
redémarré mi avril
chaque gamme va me permettent de
travailler soit aussi bien avec un appel
d'offres public une salle de conférence
un gros centre de conférences comme on
le fait d'habitude a par exemple lancé
des oeufs ou des clients comme ça ou de
senna août ça que des commerçants ou le
restaurateur du coin avec un tiers du
chiffre d'affaires réalisé au mois de
mars cette nouvelle activité doit
permettre d'amortir cette perte
en attendant une reprise de l'activité
habituelle dans le secteur de
l'événementiel carrelage salle de bains
matériel décoratifs la société miss teen
installé à coignières connaît comme bien
d'autres entreprises des conséquences de
la crise sanitaire
si une partie de l'activité s'est
poursuivie ces dirigeants ont décidé
aussi de s'adapter
les explications dorer les onze dans
cette enseigne basée à coignières des
revêtements pour le sol des aménagements
pour la salle de bains mais aussi depuis
peu des solutions hydro-alcooliques un
produit devenu indispensable face à la
situation sanitaire que l'entreprise a
eu l'autorisation de fabriquer notre
fabricant français qui est hydro
minérale et il a eu l'autorisation
dernièrement et il s'est très vite
adapté il a eu l'autorisation de
transformer sa production s'est produit
ici on les a déjà dans un premier temps
j'irais proposer à notre clientèle
traditionnelle c'est à dire aux
entreprises du bâtiment qui ont en ont
besoin aussi à tous nos je dirais
confrères commerçants de la zone de
coignières de rambouillet et de saint
quentin en yvelines et on dirait
prochainement nous proposons ce même
produit aux particuliers suivant les
besoins
le conditionnement de 5 et 20 litres
permet en plus du lavage des mains de
prévoir une désinfection du mobilier des
locaux cette adaptation de l'entreprise
lui a notamment permis de conserver une
activité plus soutenue alors que l'accès
au magasin était uniquement réservé aux
professionnels
aujourd'hui seule la moitié des 11
salariés sont en chômage partiel
cette activité de production et
distribution de solutions
hydroalcooliques pourrait se poursuivre
encore quelques temps on arrive à une
situation de façon rapide parce qu'il
faut le faire et on y est
voilà on est dans notre jeu peut être
notre nouveau métier mission d'urgence
soit encore action solidaire et sociale
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
une dizaine de bénévoles de la
protection civile des yvelines se
relaient chaque jour sur le terrain
touché économiquement de plein fouet la
protection civile lance un appel à la
générosité publique et ce pour la
première fois de son histoire la
protection civile a une mission sur
plusieurs volets la première sur une
action en action sociale on est présent
continu les maraudes sociales
on est présent auprès d'un agriculteur à
ecully pour pouvoir l'aider dans
l'enquêté commandée et on a également ce
qui est la spécificité la protection
civile l'action sur le ce plan en effet
nos équipes sont présents depuis le
début auprès du samu des yvelines pour
aller vers les malades à domicile et
pouvoir les transporter déjà un pur
élevé doute et éventuellement d'aller
les transporter sur les hôpitaux du
secteur à la demande
à la demande du salut nous avons
également en liaison avec les autorités
publiques des missions dans les ehpad 1
est différent
opérations de logistique par exemple
dans les hôpitaux où un accueil à la
fois le public et on a une mission de
renfort dans les urgences auprès des
hôpitaux de poissy et mantes la jolie
[Applaudissements]
habituellement la protection civile est
financé par de bienne le premier les
formations aux premiers secours qui sont
vendus auprès des entreprises des
collectivités mais aussi des
particuliers et ensuite des différents
dispositifs qu'elle vienne de secours
que l'on fait on des organisateurs
privés ou des organisateurs public ses
activités à l'heure actuelle ce contrat
la reconquête de ne pas parler demande
aussi du gouvernement puisqu'il n'ya
plus l'événement il n'y a plus de
formation aux premiers secours
à l'heure actuelle on a une demande
exponentielle de mission qu'il ya des
nouvelles missions qui vont se rajouter
à ça et c'est pour cette raison qu'on a
besoin de financements pour pouvoir
continuer ses missions la protection
civile à 99% depuis son existence n'a
pas pour habitude de se financer par la
générosité publique qui est un mot qui
est pour l'instant nous inconnu et qui
prend vraiment du sens pendant cette
histoire
[Musique]
alors la première possibilité la plus
simple c'est d'envoyer dons par sms au
92 3 92
donc on l'envoie on envoie simplement le
don et ses 5 euros qui est directement
débité de sa facture téléphonique tous
les opérateurs jouent le jeu à
l'exception de free c'est important de
le citer si les personnes qui souhaitent
faire un don et rencontrent des
problèmes pour pouvoir faire un don par
sms où il souhaite tout simplement
donner plus de 5 euros
il suffit de se rendre sur le site
internet de la protection civile des
yvelines où ils ont l'occasion de faire
un don et si ils préfèrent envoyer un
chèque le virement
ils nous contactent et on leur donnera
la barre réponses aux questions qu'ils
se posent confort nous donner sachant
que l'ensemble des dons qui choix de 5e
ronde qui sera le plus sont entièrement
déductibles des impôts
direction le sud yvelines avec over the
blues cette association a rassemblé des
bénévoles pour élaborer des surblouse
pour le personnel soignant qui manque de
matériel médical
une centaine de couturière a sorti les
machines à coudre mathilde de 2010 est
allé à leur rencontre
regardez j'ai récupéré des choses à
saint-léger-en-yvelines marie claude a
ramené des draps et différents tissus
donné par le voisinage
le petit groupe de bénévoles de
l'association over the blues créer du
matériel pour le personnel soignant
c'est très important il ya des gens qui
ont besoin des chiroux loose et c'est
très important de pouvoir mais ça ne
marche que si on est nombreux pour
pouvoir avoir chacun quelque chose à
faire et parce que chaque blouson mais
au moins trois heures pour les coudre
simplement
après ça va il faut traiter de clichy
c'est à dire leur passé il faut le
préparer tout ça c'est très long dans
cet atelier les bénévoles découpe chaque
morceau de tissu grâce à des patrons qui
serviront à créer les surblouse les
manches le buste sans oublier les
élastiques tout doit être prêt pour
faciliter la couture ici effectivement
en découpe tout on assemble on a des
élastiques over the blues man a passé
quelques mètres moi j'en avais aussi
métrage à la maison donc on prépare tout
après les filles qui y poussent donc
envoie un sms pour me dire est-ce qu'on
peut passer à la salle à quelle heure
elles viennent chercher des blues à
coudre et elle me les ramènent quelques
jours après une fois les pièces
constituées elles sont repassées est
envoyé aux soignants mari de robillard
est une des co gérants à l'initiative du
projet elle s'occupe de la logistique
entre les couturières bénévoles
on est tous un bénévole et qui a un
livre est déjà plus de 700 vraiment je
remercie tous ces bénévoles qui est
vraiment réussie machines des blues qui
ont rejoint les hôpitaux et les centres
yvelinois pour les soignants qui sont en
première ligne face aux cours aux
navires russes c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis
rester à votre domicile et prenez soin
de vous et on se quitte sur cet extrait
du chanteur algérien idir héros de la
chanson kabyle il nous a quitté ce
samedi 2 mai à l'âge de 70 ans il était
venu faire un concert à la merise
attrape le 10 février 2018 passé une
excellente soirée sur tv 70
[Musique]
pas
l'officier
[Musique]